ex los hier im hamburger flughafen aber
dafür demnächst bei klicks so wenn es
nämlich heißt bellum et pax und das
bedeutet nicht dass ein lehrer zu mir
kommt sondern der rapper fard und er hat
sich diesen titel ausgesucht ja warum
eigentlich das werde ich ihn fragen das
heißt nämlich übersetzt krieg und
frieden
aber warum in latein vielleicht nur was
für abiturienten
schauen wir mal was er dazu sagen wird
und was er zu euren fragen sagen wird
die ihr hier
unter dem video in den kommentaren
posten könnt oder als video antwort eure
fragen hochladen und dann kann
eigentlich nichts mehr schief gehen wenn
sie wie immer kreativ sind einfallsreich
und schlau